jack est maintenant stéphane guillon
s'est même dit on nomme monsieur
donc pour cette dernière vous avez
décidé de remettre des prix stéphane
marie parce que sans nos amis people je
ne serais rien j'ai voulu les remercier
à ma manière le prix du courage revient
à nicolas hulot qui pour dénoncer la
reprise de la pêche au thon à peloter
dominique voynet
prix remis également à titre posthume à
rostropovitch embrasser dans son
cercueil par bernadette chirac ça fout
la trouille
pour la petite histoire j'ai accueilli
médiatement rendu la monnaie de sa pièce
à bernadette en embrassant lui aussi une
momie
le prix de la grande froideur très
disputé ex-aequo les salariés de la
société picard et les deux bébés
courjault
c'est plus noir
ça fait rire les urgentistes
non il ya des prix c'est très difficile
de trancher par exemple le prix de la
laine de bouc entre la jument de
françois bayrou bernard kouchner houmam
c'était très difficile de deux
[Applaudissements]
prix du fayot à vha robert robert permet
au président de franchir tous les
obstacles
et sur cette deuxième photo le président
attend que robert lui apporte un cube
pour poser ses jambes merci robert
le prix de la rupture ségolène et assoit
il avait tout pour être heureux ségolène
imitait bécassine comme personne
françois jurés partout qu'il en avait
une grosse
le jour de leur rencontre il s'était
offert le même attaché case
facétieux françois glissé parfois une
rose dans la culotte de sa moitié
aujourd'hui c'est benoît son chagrin
dans l'alcool
et françois s'est acheté un nouveau
costume pour [ __ ]
de la plus belle imitation jacques
chirac dans questions pour un champion
otg par mon immunité parlementaire
durant douze ans je suis à nouveau un
citoyen ordinaire qui qui qui qui
suis-je
ouais
c'était pas fascinant c'était
des doutes
le tri de la camaraderie françois fillon
il aime tellement sarkozy qui choppe la
migraine à sa place
le prêt nauséabond où prix qui pue
georges frêche pascal sevran et
dieudonné à égalité
le prix du traître
impossible a décerné cette année trop de
monde on passe on termine par les prix
qui ne bouge pas chaque année ils
conservent leur titre hélas ne
manifestaient pas parce que c'est
parfois douloureux pour eux
prix de l'animateur le plus antipathique
prix du micropénis
prix de l'encéphalogramme plat
à une exception quand même le prix de la
plus belle mort sur sultan le chien qui
avait mordu isabelle dinoire 700 titres
à jean luc delarue voir
et enfin
dernier prix remis à titre personnel le
prix de la sympathie va à toute l'équipe
de scènes d'intérieur merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu